[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PIANO PLAYING]
[CHOIR SINGING]
CHOIR (SINGING): Hallelujah.
Praise the Lord.
Hallelujah.
Praise him with [INAUDIBLE].
Praise him on the [INAUDIBLE].
Everything that has breath
ought to praise him.
Hallelujah.
Praise the Lord.
[INAUDIBLE] Lord.
Praise him with [INAUDIBLE].
Praise him on the [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] Everything that
has breath ought to praise him.
Hallelujah.
Let us praise the Lord.
[APPLAUSE]
MAN: Check one, two.
[PIANO PLAYING]
CHOIR (SINGING): [INAUDIBLE]
a word that comes and goes.
[INAUDIBLE] Love, though
the tears may fade away.
[INAUDIBLE] Because I
love you, and you've
shown me, Jesus, what it
really means [INAUDIBLE]..
A word that comes and goes.
[INAUDIBLE] somebody.
Love, though the
tears may fade away.
[INAUDIBLE] your love will
stay because I love you,
and you've shown me, Jesus,
what it really means to love.
The nights that I
cried, you loved me.
[INAUDIBLE] I'll never
know why you love me.
[INAUDIBLE] Now I'm glad to say
Jesus, when all hope was gone,
you loved me.
You gave me a song,
and you love me.
[INAUDIBLE] love me.
[INAUDIBLE]
Now I'm glad to say Jesus,
[INAUDIBLE] you loved me.
When I should have
died, you loved me.
[INAUDIBLE] Now I'm glad to say
Jesus, when all hope was gone,
you loved me.
[INAUDIBLE] love me.
Now I can go on
because you love me.
[INAUDIBLE]
Now I'm glad to say Jesus.
[INAUDIBLE] really means
to love.
[INAUDIBLE] Patient.
Kind.
That's love.
Patient.
Kind.
That's love.
Ooh.
What it really means,
what it really means,
what it really means to love.
SMITH: Good morning.
Good morning.
If I could have people start
gathering to their seats
So we can begin this morning's
breakfast, that would be great.
Thank you.
[PIANO PLAYING]
CHOIR (SINGING): [INAUDIBLE]
lay down my burdens
down by the riverside,
down by the riverside, down
by the riverside.
I'm going to lay down my
burdens down by the riverside,
study war no more.
Study war no more, study war
no more, study war no more.
I'm going to lay down
my sword and shield
down by the riverside,
down by the riverside, down
by the riverside.
I'm going to lay down
my sword and shield down
by the riverside.
Study war no more.
Study war no more, study war
no more, study war no more.
I'm going to lay
down my burdens down
by the riverside, down
by the riverside.
I'm going to lay down my
burdens down by the riverside.
Study war no more.
Study war no more, study war
no more, study war no more.
Study war no more.
[APPLAUSE]
[PIANO PLAYING]
Freedom.
Every woman and child
deserves freedom.
Freedom.
Every woman and child
deserves freedom.
Martin, just like Moses,
is saying, Pharaoh,
set my people free.
How long is it going
to take before you're
able to see that if one of my
brothers or one of my sisters
is deprived of liberty,
that means none of us,
oh, no, none of us is
ever really, truly free?
Give me freedom.
Freedom.
Every woman and child
deserves freedom.
Freedom.
Every woman and child
deserves freedom.
And child deserves freedom.
[APPLAUSE]
SMITH: Good morning, everyone.
Good morning.
My name is Shana Smith,
and I am currently
a senior in civil
engineering here at MIT
and have the pleasure of being
your mistress of ceremonies
for this morning's breakfast.
So I would like to officially
welcome you to the 25th Annual
Dr. Martin Li--
excuse me-- Dr. Martin
Luther King, Jr. Breakfast
Celebration.
I'd first like to
take an opportunity
to thank President Charles
Vest and his wife, Mrs. Rebecca
Vest, for hosting this event.
I would also like to
thank the honorable Kweisi
Mfume, president and CEO
of the National Association
for the Advancement of
Colored People, for being here
today with us also.
We really appreciate having you.
Furthermore, I would like to
thank the members of the Martin
Luther King Jr.
Committee to whom we
can thank for this
breakfast and this event.
When I call your names, can you
please stand and be recognized?
Professor Jerome Friedman.
[APPLAUSE]
Professor Kenneth Hale.
Professor Wesley Harris.
[APPLAUSE]
Professor Richard Milner.
Assistant Professor
Melissa Nobles.
[APPLAUSE]
Assistant Professor
Larry Anderson.
[APPLAUSE]
Associate Dean
Arnold Henderson, Jr.
[APPLAUSE]
Assistant Dean Ann Davis Shaw.
Ronald Crishlow.
[APPLAUSE]
The Reverend Jane Gould.
Yvette Lane.
[APPLAUSE]
Trudy Morris.
Paul Paravano.
[APPLAUSE]
Robert Sales.
Toby Wiener.
[APPLAUSE]
Associate Provost
Phillip Clay, ex-officio.
[APPLAUSE]
Special Assistant
to the President,
Dr. Clarence G.
Williams, ex-officio.
[APPLAUSE]
Jennifer Martinez.
Laurie Smith Britain.
[APPLAUSE]
And finally, we'd also like to
thank the co-chairs, Dean Leo
Osgood Jr.
[APPLAUSE]
And Professor Michael Feld.
Thank you all.
In addition, we'd also like
to express our appreciation
to the many student volunteers
who were here very early
this morning to help with the
preparations for this event.
Thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
We begin the program
with the invocation
by Rabbi Joshua Eli Plout.
Following the invocation,
the MIT Gospel Choir
will sing us a song, I believe.
And finally,
breakfast will begin.
After breakfast, we
will have two students--
Maribel Gomez, class of
2002, and Randall Pinkett,
a graduate student--
guide us in a reflection on the
life and legacy of Dr. King.
Then we will hear some
remarks from Dr. Charles Vest,
and he will have the
distinct pleasure
of introducing our keynote
speaker, the honorable Kweisi
Mfume, president and
CEO of the NAACP.
Chancellor Lawrence
S. Bachau will
present the 1998-1999 Martin
Luther King Leadership Awards,
and following that presentation,
Provost Robert A. Brown
will recognize our
Dr. Martin Luther
King, Jr. visiting professors
for the 1998-99 academic year.
So as a conclusion
to the program,
the MIT Gospel Choir will
again perform and lead us
as we also join in singing "Lift
Every Voice and Sing" by James
Weldon Johnson.
Now let us begin our
program with the invocation
by Rabbi Joshua Eli Plout.
And right after Rabbi
Plout's invocation,
we can begin breakfast.
How about that?
PLOUT: Coming
together this morning
to warm each other's souls, to
inspire one another to continue
the struggle for
equality, let us listen to
and let us act upon
the commandments found
in the Bible.
In the Book of Exodus, God
calls upon each one of us
to teach our sons and
daughters, to teach them
the story of the exodus
from Egypt, the liberation
from the house of bondage.
This duty of
teaching our children
diligently is repeated in
the Book of Deuteronomy.
There, we are commanded to
love God with all of our mind,
with all of our strength,
and with all of our being,
to set these sacred words which
are commanded upon our hearts,
to teach them faithfully
to our children,
to speak of them in our home
and on our way when we lie down
and when we rise up.
And we should bind them
as a sign upon our hand
and let them be a
symbol before our eyes,
inscribing them on the
door posts of our house
and on our gates.
Scripture commands us that
teaching and learning,
the vehicles of education, are
not a privilege, but a duty.
Learning and teaching are
active states of being.
Day and night, let us labor to
bring the fruits of education
to every person, to
erase the inequalities
in educational opportunity
which so afflict our society,
and let us search for
and then reach out
to help those who are at a
disadvantage to empower them
with all of the knowledge and
wisdom, the skills and learning
experiences that will be the key
that opens the door to a better
and more just life.
On this morning,
we gather to honor
the spirit of Martin Luther
King, Jr, a blessed memory,
to carry on and transmit the
legacy he has bequeathed.
As we now carry his torch
and this generation,
let us keep in mind that
every generation that
inherits the
victories of the past
will not enjoy them unless
it strives to understand,
appreciate, and cherish them
as though they themselves
have fought for them.
Each generation must
discover freedom anew.
Each must ever earn
its claim to liberty.
Let us therefore
each ask of ourselves
how we intend, as individuals,
to bring equal educational
and work opportunity
to those in need,
how we intend in our own way to
carry the torch of yesteryear.
Looking back in time, I think
of my late father, Walter Plout,
a rabbi who was a
Freedom Rider in 1962
fighting the battle to
desegregate public facilities
in Georgia and Florida.
His heartfelt
responsibility is now mine,
and I, like the rest
of us in this room,
have a responsibility to
face the unique challenges
of inequality in
our own generation,
continuing the work of
those who came before us.
As we sit and break
bread together and listen
and discuss on this great
morning of celebration
of the life and the spirit
of Martin Luther King, Jr,
let us be grateful for
this wonderful opportunity
of a community coming together,
striving to forever renew
a shared vision.
Let us remember
that after all, we
are here at this great
Institute of research,
learning, and teaching
because we accept our mission
to be proactive in fulfilling
the dream of providing teaching
and learning experiences
for every American in need.
And while a good meal
now awaits us all,
there is much more
to anticipate.
A 2000-year-old Jewish
saying from the Talmud
reminds us that the person who
teaches his or her neighbor's
child will deserve to sit
in the heavenly academy.
So may be our will and our way.
Amen.
CHOIR (SINGING):
Ain't going to let
nobody, Lordy, turn me around,
turn me around, turn me around.
Ain't going to let nobody,
Lordy, turn me around.
Keep on walking.
Keep on talking, walking
on to Freedom Land.
Ain't gonna let segregation,
Lordy, turn me around, turn me
around, turn me around.
Ain't gonna let's segregation,
Lordy, turn me around.
Keep on walking.
Keep on talking, walking
on to Freedom Land.
Ain't gonna let racism,
Lordy, turn me around, turn me
around, turn me around.
Ain't gonna let racism,
Lordy, turn me around.
Keep on walking.
Keep on talking, walking
on to Freedom Land.
Ain't gonna let sexism,
Lordy, turn me around, turn me
around, turn me around.
Ain't gonna let sexism,
Lordy, turn me around.
Keep on walking.
Keep on talking, walking
on to Freedom Land.
Ain't gonna let the devil,
Lordy, turn me around, turn me
around, turn me around.
Ain't gonna let the devil,
Lordy, turn me around.
Keep on walking.
Keep on talking, walking
on to Freedom Land.
[APPLAUSE]
SMITH: We're ready to continue
on with this morning's program.
Welcome back.
I hope you all have enjoyed your
breakfast as much as I have.
We can now go on.
I have the distinct
pleasure of introducing
two of our very own students--
Maribel Gomez, a freshman
in chemical engineering,
and Randall Pinkett,
a graduate student
in media arts and sciences.
Each will share and guide
us through some thoughts
and reflections on the life
and legacy of Dr. King.
So I'd like to
introduce Maribel Gomez.
[APPLAUSE]
GOMEZ: Good morning, everyone.
My name is Maribel
Gomez, and I'm
a member of the class of
2002, and I'm currently
pursuing a degree in
chemical engineering.
In the 25 years since his death,
Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr,
has become an American hero.
As we remember the life
and dream of Dr. King,
we remember the injustices
that Dr. King fought for,
his fight for freedom, equality,
and dignity for all races
and people, his many
speeches that awakened people
to the horrors of
racial discrimination,
and his work that spanned
and touched all minorities
and motivated them to action.
We remember, but we must
also act on his dream.
To do this, we must
follow Dr. King's example
and educate ourselves--
educate ourselves on
the meaning and message
of such a great educator
and those whom inspired him.
Martin Luther King's ideas,
his call for racial equality,
his faith in the
ultimate triumph
of justice, his insistence
on the power of nonviolence
to bring a major transformation
on American society
are as vital and timely as ever.
His life and teachings have
had a profound influence
not only on Americans, but
of people of all nations.
Dr. King said,
"Nothing in this world
is more dangerous
than sincere ignorance
and conscientious stupidity."
Nothing in this world
is more dangerous
than sincere ignorance and
conscientious stupidity.
We are such a diverse,
multicultural nation
that we can no longer
tolerate injustices
based on the color of our skin.
We must empower ourselves
with our knowledge
and become educators ourselves
to those who are ignorant.
History is still unfolding.
Our actions today will be
the history of tomorrow.
We must act accordingly.
We must respond to
the words he preached.
I quote, "We are faced with the
fact that tomorrow is today.
We are confronted with
the fierce urgency of now.
In this unfolding conundrum
of life and history,
there is such a thing
as being too late.
Let us not be too late.
Let us not be too late."
Let us all live and act
by the words of Dr. King.
Let us educate those around us
of the joys of living together
in harmony, and let
him continue to inspire
us to perform extraordinary acts
of courage and perseverance,
just like he did
when he ignited one
of the most influential civil
rights and economic movements
of the 20th century.
I'd like to leave with
Dr. King's quote again
as a reminder.
"Nothing in this world
is more dangerous
than sincere ignorance and
conscientious stupidity."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SMITH: Thank you very,
very, very much, Maribel,
for those inspiring and
thought-provoking remarks.
We will now proceed with
Mr. Randall Pinkett.
Randall?
PINKETT: Thank you, Shana.
Good morning.
Somewhere I once heard that
the great figures among us
have been ordinary people that
have done extraordinary things.
The Reverend Dr.
Martin Luther King, Jr,
did extraordinary things.
But at the same time--
and I don't think I diminish
Dr. King's great legacy
by saying this--
he was an ordinary man,
an ordinary man that
did ordinary things
until December 1, 1955,
when Rosa Parks
refused to give up
her seat on a bus in
Montgomery, Alabama,
and Dr. King, at the age
of 26 and just barely out
of graduate school, was placed
at a crossroad along the path
that constitutes human history.
It was then that this
man, this ordinary man,
became a great figure and
did extraordinary things.
Robert Frost wrote, "Two
roads diverged in a wood,
and I, I took the
one less traveled by.
And that has made
all the difference."
But in recognition
of Dr. King's legacy,
I pose the following question.
What about when
there is no road?
Hmm?
What about when there is
no road, no path to follow?
Of the many things I've
learned from Dr. King's life,
high among them is the
notion that each of us,
in our own unique way, is
embarking on a new path
with each passing
moment, venturing
into uncharted territory.
And while there are points and
places and moments and times
where our paths cross and
intersect and intertwine,
no two paths are alike.
The honorable Mr.
Mfume has walked
along a path, his own path.
Our honorees today-- Mr.
Williamson, Ms. [INAUDIBLE],,
and Professor Slocum-- have
walked along their own paths.
And the Reverend Dr.
Martin Luther King, Jr,
walked along his path.
So I ask the question once
again, ladies and gentlemen.
What about when
there is no road?
The answer?
The road is made as one walks.
Honoring the life and
legacy of Dr. King
means remembering that just
as he walked along his path
and was able to do great
things, we must walk along
our path knowing that we,
too, can do great things,
because if we put Dr. King
too high on a pedestal,
if we allow his
accomplishments to in some way
become unachievable
or unattainable,
then not only do
we do a disservice
to his life and
his legacy, but we
diminish our own capacity
as ordinary people
to do extraordinary things.
God bless you, and God
bless you, Dr. King.
[APPLAUSE]
SMITH: Once again, I'd like to
thank both Maribel and Randall
for sharing their thoughts
and remarks on Dr. King.
I hope that everyone
here has had a chance
to really take in what was said
and reflect for themselves.
I would like to now introduce
the 15th President of MIT, Dr.
Charles M. Vest, who
will give some remarks
and then introduce our keynote
speaker, the honorable Kweisi
Mfume.
President Vest?
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Thank you, Shana.
Mr. Mfume, at least you
get me between those kids
and yourself.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Before I begin my
remarks, I want
to take a moment to recognize
several distinguished
representatives of
the larger Cambridge
community who have joined
with us for today's program.
From the Cambridge
City Council, I'm
very pleased to welcome
our current mayor, Frank
[INAUDIBLE],, and also his
predecessor, City Councilor Ken
Reeves.
We also are very pleased
to have with us--
[APPLAUSE]
We also are very pleased to
have with us City Councilor
Catherine [INAUDIBLE];;
the Cambridge Police
Commissioner, Ronnie
Watson; the Mayor's School
Liaison, Ann-Leigh Foster;
the Mayor's Chief of Staff,
[INAUDIBLE];; and the
Coordinator of the Mayor's
Initiative on Race and
Class, Michelle Farnam.
Welcome to all of you.
[APPLAUSE]
We're also delighted to welcome
to this morning's events
a delegation of leaders from the
Cambridge Public School System,
which is establishing its own
dialogue on race relations
under the guidance of school
committee member Denise
Simmons.
Ms. Simmons is with us today.
[APPLAUSE]
And accompanying her, fellow
school committee member
Robin Harris, Superintendent
of Schools Bobby Del Sandro,
and Deputy Superintendent
Patrick Murphy.
Welcome to all of you.
[APPLAUSE]
I think it's fair to say that
MIT and the city of Cambridge
are on a shared journey, and the
ways in which we work together
in education, development,
and civic affairs
is something that gives me
great confidence in our future.
It's good to have all of
you here this morning.
Just four years ago, the
keynote speaker for this event
was Judge A. Leon Higginbotham,
Jr. This past year,
after a half century
of service as one
of our nation's foremost
jurists, scholars,
and advocates for civil
rights, Judge Higginbotham
was taken from us.
I could not let
this occasion pass
without saying a few words about
this truly extraordinary man.
Leon Higginbotham was a
hero for many Americans.
Here at MIT, we will
forever be grateful
for his compelling and
effective advocacy on our behalf
during what became known
as the overlap case.
As many in this room
remember, in 1991,
the United States
Justice Department
brought an antitrust suit
against MIT and against the Ivy
League universities,
alleging collusion
in the way in which we award
financial aid to our students.
We argued that our
practices sought
to ensure that students would
be awarded financial aid solely
on the basis of
their financial need
and that different schools would
not get into financial bidding
wars for students.
Judge Higginbotham,
who had recently
retired from the bench, believed
our case was so compelling
that he volunteered to present
pro-bono the amici briefs
on our behalf at
the appellate court.
A staunch and
effective supporter
of affirmative
action and diversity,
Leon Higginbotham argued
that the principles at stake
in the overlap case had to
do with both public policy
and ethical norms, and
one of those norms,
he said, and I quote here, was
that "those people who are poor
but who are talented should
have the same opportunity
to have an entry into
these great universities
as did the Kennedys
and the Rockefellers
and the Cabots and the Lodges."
One of the reasons he
worked so hard to preserve
the practice of
need-blind admission
and need-based financial
aid was his recognition
that this policy was
a blessing not only
for those who receive
the opportunity,
but for the larger
society as well.
After he had made his argument
to the appellate court,
an argument that prevailed,
Judge Higginbotham
got a letter from
an antitrust lawyer
who had heard his
presentation to the court.
That lawyer observed that
in the future, quote,
"many poor white kids will
get into Ivy League schools,
and they will not recognize that
this option was made possible
because of the arguments
of a black lawyer
and the Congressional Black
Caucus made on behalf of MIT
for all of the poor
kids of America."
As Judge Higginbotham reminded
us when he spoke here in 1995,
we meet here today
to acknowledge
that Martin Luther King's legacy
was not merely to black people
or to brown people.
His legacy was one that
embraced all people.
This is perhaps the
least understood and most
misrepresented aspect of the
ongoing debate over policies
designed to promote more
equal opportunity and greater
diversity in American society.
Leon Higginbotham knew
that society could not
progress unless it
progressed as a whole,
with no one left
behind or pushed aside.
Today, this fundamental policy,
this fundamental principle,
is again under direct assault.
Across America, the old cry
of "your gain is
my loss" is heard
on college campuses,
corporate boardrooms,
and the halls of Congress.
It is a matter of profound and
disturbing irony that at a time
of unparalleled prosperity, many
of those who have the most--
the most wealth, the most
access, the most skills,
the most power--
seem to be more
reluctant than ever
to invest those resources in
a strong and just society.
In order to bring that strength
and justice to our society,
all of us must continue
to think on and speak out
about the issue of
race-sensitive admissions
in American higher education.
Since 1978, our colleges
and universities
have designed and administered
admissions policies
under the guidance of
the Bakke decision,
which was forged in the Supreme
Court by Thurgood Marshall.
This guidance is clear.
Race may be one of
several factors considered
when we select students for
admissions to our campuses.
This simple statement, in my
view, is the appropriate one.
Under it, as Bill Bowen
and Derek Bok have clearly
demonstrated in their recent
book, The Shape of the River,
our institutions have
contributed substantially
to the establishment of a
strong black middle class,
and therefore, to the
strengthening of America
as a whole, but the quest
is far from complete.
Today, through referenda
such as Proposition 209
in California,
Initiative Measure
200 in the state of
Washington, public universities
are losing their
ability to utilize
race-sensitive admissions
or even the ability
to mount outreach
programs to minority
youngsters in primary
and secondary schools.
From MIT'S point of
view, more dangerous
still are successful attacks
in the courts, especially
the Hopwood case dealing with
admission to the University
of Texas Law School.
A case involving
undergraduate admissions
at the University of Michigan
currently pending in the courts
may be the most
important to date.
Now, many argue on behalf
of these referenda and court
challenges, and do
so in good faith,
that it is discriminatory
to make race
a consideration in
admissions and that students
should be admitted only on
what they consider to be merit.
In my view, there are two,
quite elementary flaws
in this argument.
First, we have
laid upon the table
several factors, things such
as grades, ranks in class,
test scores, geographic
distribution, breadth
of interest, unusual
accomplishments
outside the classroom,
race, economic status,
international mixture,
and so forth and so on.
Those who challenge us reach
out and remove from the table
one and only one factor--
race-- and say, thou
shalt not consider this.
Second, their
underlying assumption
is that we can
accurately measure
specific quality
of our applicants
by a simple number or two.
They seem to seek a world
in which we are each
ranked at age 18 by some easy
indicator like an SAT score
which thereby determines
our breadth of opportunity.
We believe that building a
class for a great university
by using a range of
factors promotes a better
educational experience
for all of our students,
and that it
increases our ability
to contribute to building the
strong, coherent, productive
society this nation will
need in the next century.
The logic underlying
this belief,
to use a favorite MIT phrase,
is intuitively obvious,
yet far too many of us still
cannot seem to understand
the old patterns of exclusion
and separation did not work
and must not be restored.
They don't work for
society, and they really
don't work for individuals.
To the contrary,
individual fulfillment
is enabled and enhanced
by participation
in the larger community.
Here on our campus, the recently
issued report of the Task Force
on Student Life and
Learning reminds us
that excellence in
research and education
arise not only from
individual efforts,
but also from commingling of
diverse ideas, perspectives,
challenge of competition and
of teamwork, and the support
of a nurturing community.
The message underlying the
task force's recommendation
is that MIT must become more
than just the sum of its parts,
and in order to educate a
new generation of leaders
for an increasingly
interconnected global society,
we must, by our own
example, show students
how to function,
communicate, and thrive
in a diverse environment.
One promising effort in
community-building at MIT
is occurring in our
facilities department
and on our campus police force,
where working and managing
in a diverse environment
is made an explicit part
of each person's
career development.
While the program
is relatively new,
early evidence suggests
that the direct attention
to training and evaluation
and managing such issues
can improve communication,
productivity, and employee
satisfaction for everyone.
Of course, many of the
same pressures and problems
that affect our larger
society remain part
of our everyday life at MIT.
We're still only
at the beginning
of a long and difficult journey.
I hope, however, that even
in times of controversy,
we hold onto the
example of such leaders
as Dr. King and
Judge Higginbotham--
remind us that our journey
cannot be completed alone.
Unless all of us
help and each of us--
unless all of us help
each to make our own way,
we will never realize
the highest potential
we have for excellence
and achievement.
In designing our
admissions policies,
in shaping our curricula,
and advising our students
and working together,
we must never
lose sight of the
truth expressed
in these words written
by James Taylor
to honor the memory of Dr. King.
"We are bound together by
the tasks that lie before us
and the road that lies ahead.
We are bound, and we are bound."
Thank you again very much
for being here this morning
and for sharing this small
part of a great journey.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, it's my
pleasure and honor
to introduce this
morning's keynote speaker,
the honorable Kweisi Mfume,
president and CEO of the NAACP.
This annual ceremony
commemorating Dr. Martin Luther
King, Jr, has been an important
feature of the MIT calendar
for the last quarter century.
Over that time, we have been
graced with many fine speakers,
each of whom has made
a unique contribution
to the history and
the cumulative impact
of this event.
The experience and achievements
of this year's keynote speaker,
however, are so
impressive and so relevant
that it would be difficult to
conceive of a better or more
welcome choice.
His own life journey is witness
to the transforming influence
of determination,
education, and vision
in the life of an
individual and to society.
Raised in Baltimore's
inner city,
he graduated from
Morgan State University
and from the Johns
Hopkins School
of International Studies.
He then began his political
career back on home ground
as a Baltimore city councilman.
In 1986, he was
elected to Congress,
where he served for 10
years as representative
of Maryland's seventh district.
In the course of his
Congressional career,
Mr. Mfume was a
powerful advocate
for landmark legislation
affecting civil rights
and economic development.
During his tenure
in Congress, he
served as chair of the
Joint Senate-House Economic
Committee, and his other
committee assignments
included the Ethics Committee,
Banking and Financial Services
Committee, the
Committee on Education,
and the Small
Business Committee.
In 1996, he resigned
from Congress
to assume the
presidency of the NAACP,
where his leadership has
had a significant impact
on a wide range of
civil rights issues.
In addition to his
work with the NAACP,
Mr. Mfume is active in the
world of higher education.
He serves on the Morgan State
University Board of Regents,
the Senior Advisory Committee
in the John F. Kennedy School
of Government at
Harvard University,
the Meyerhoff National Advisory
Board of the University
of Maryland, and the board
of trustees of the Enterprise
Foundation, and I believe
from our table conversation
also on the Johns
Hopkins board now.
He's a member of Big
Brothers and Big Sisters,
and he is the author of
a critically acclaimed
autobiography
entitled No Free Ride.
When it comes to equal
opportunity and social progress
for all Americans, we could
seek no stronger advocate.
Please join me in welcoming
the honorable Kweisi Mfume.
[APPLAUSE]
MFUME: Thank you very much.
Allow me, if I might,
to begin my remarks
by thanking Dr.
Vest for those kind
and overly gracious
set of comments,
and for his leadership at
this historic university,
but probably this morning,
more than anything else,
for being a buffer between me
and the two very impressive
students that spoke before me.
I am particularly
happy, Dr. Vest,
that you invoked the name
of Leon Higginbotham, who
was a very dear
friend and probably
the most important reason why
I left my work in the Congress
to join the NAACP.
After many conversations
with Judge Higginbotham
and after many opportunities
to understand his reasoning as
to why it was important
for me to do that,
I ultimately did just
that and was here
just a couple of months
ago to participate
in his home-going
service and would
say to particularly
students who may have not
had the opportunity to
meet Leon Higginbotham
that you find a way to
either get to the library
or to get back on the
internet or to get
to someone who did to find
out about this extraordinary
individual.
I'd also like to thank
all of the people who
have made this morning's
event possible,
and there are a lot of them.
And I was particularly
happy last night
that I got a chance
to meet many of them.
I'd like, if I might, on a
point of personal privilege
to really thank Dr. Leo Osgood
and Professor Michael Feld.
They have, through perhaps
some difficulty but more
importantly, through a number
of different circumstances
that we probably
are not aware of,
continued to find a way
to make this possible
and to remind all of us
about the need to take time
to commemorate and to remember.
I want to also say to Provost
Robert Brown and all the others
who have worked very hard on
this event that I do thank you,
and I know I speak on behalf
of students who are here
and those who are not
who recognize now,
even if it is in hindsight, how
important this remembrance is.
To Ms. Gomez and Mr. Pinkett,
I want to thank both of you
for your energy,
for the opportunity
to meet you last night, but
more importantly, for the energy
and the sense of
understanding you displayed
a little while ago
with respect to why
it is important to remember.
And I'd also, if I might,
like to acknowledge,
as was the case
earlier, the presence
of the mayor of Cambridge
and many, many other honored
guests, not the
least of which are
several distinguished members
of our organization, our state
conference president here in the
New England area, Ms. Charlotte
Nelson, who is
somewhere out there--
Charlotte-- and the presidents
of our Boston and Cambridge
chapters, Lennie
Alkins, Jackie Carol.
I know [INAUDIBLE] is
here and a few others.
Thank all of you for coming
out and supporting me
and for coming out also to
work with this community
as you do day in and day out.
Could we give all of those
persons a round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
I bring you greetings
this morning
on behalf of the NAACP--
our 1,700 branches
and 50 states,
the District of Columbia,
Germany, Japan, and Korea.
At the National Association
for the Advancement of Colored
People, we believe that colored
people come in all colors,
for it was the NAACP
that saw America
through the troubled
years of Jim
Crow and second-class
citizenship
and legal lynchings, through
the years of manufactured
grandfather clauses and poll
taxes and literacy tests where
you had to tell how many
bubbles were in a bar of soap
just to be allowed to vote.
We fought over the
years the just fight
to integrate the military and to
end official segregation as we
knew it, and we found also a
way to help a nation divided
against itself through the
confusion and the turbulence
of the 1960s, and then
later, through the I-isms
and the differences
of the 1980s.
And so it is not for
us a matter of having
come a long, long way,
but rather and instead, it
is a matter of having still
yet a long, long way to go.
That, in turn, begs the question
not when do we get there,
but what path do we take?
And that is where your themes
of teaching and learning
and inclusion come into play.
You see, the light really
does burn bright here
at and for MIT.
You are a place in many
respects where, for some people,
dreams have come
true and given birth
to other dreams of service
and academic excellence.
You have been entrusted
with a mighty vision,
and you have proven in many
respects to be worthy stewards.
Some of you have worked
hard to make sure
that your talents are
not buried in the ground,
but rather invested
well in the arts
and in the minds of our greatest
asset, our young people.
The late Dr. Benjamin
Mays of Morehouse College
once said that he or
she who starts behind
in the race of life would
either have to run faster
or forever remain behind.
Young men and
women who have kept
this tradition of
remembering alive now
for all these 25 years,
in fact, have run faster.
And so I applaud
them and those brave
souls, no matter how small
in number they may be,
who labor here at
this university, who,
like tillers of
the soil, continue
to push and to prod and cajole
for a greater university
commitment to diversity
and equal opportunity.
They know almost intuitively
that our ability as a nation
to survive will
depend particularly
on how we deal with
our increasingly
pluralistic society.
And so as a preface
to my remarks,
I would challenge others
today to take the route
that those individuals
have taken.
It is one of embracing
diversity while seeking
to promote reciprocal
understandings,
recognizing as we do
that quite frankly,
it's easier to do nothing.
And so because we all
want to do something,
let's start, if we might,
by putting in proper context
the man who we have come to
commemorate this morning.
The rabbi spoke of
the Old Testament.
Let me go even beyond
the Book of Exodus
to talk for just a moment
about the Book of Genesis,
the 37th chapter, because it
underscores in many respects
the age-old desire by a lot of
people to undercut visionaries
by trying to do away
with their dreams.
It says in the 37th
chapter that "and
when they saw him from
afar, even before he
had come near to
them, they conspired
against him to slay him.
And they said one to another,
behold, the dreamer cometh.
Come now, therefore,
and let us slay him,
and we will cast him
into some old pit,
and we will say that some
evil beast has devoured him,
and we shall see what
becomes of his dream."
Martin Luther King, Jr,
un-awed by opinion, un-seduced
by flattery,
undismayed by disaster,
confronted life with the
courage of his convictions
and confronted death with
the courage of his faith.
And lest we ever forget, we are
talking about a young man, 26
years of age when his
face first appeared
on the cover of Time
magazine, 35 years of age
when he won the Nobel Peace
Prize, 39 years of age
on the afternoon of
his assassination.
It is important to
understand that because it's
important to have a full
appreciation of his capacity
and his indignation over
the absence of justice.
A Greek historian, at
least legend has it,
was once asked when would
justice ever come to Athens.
And after thinking about the
magnitude of the question,
he thoughtfully replied
that justice would never
come to Athens until all
those who were not injured
were just as indignant
as all of those who are.
And so I hope and
pray that those of you
in this room this morning
who are Caucasian or white,
that you understand the
indignity of those like myself
who are not at the
scourge of racism
and bigotry and
unequal treatment,
and that you, in your own way,
will become just as indignant.
I hope and pray that
those who are here today
who are of Asian and
Indian, Hispanic,
and Native American ancestry,
that you understand,
as we must, the real
need never to give up
on the idea of
coalition building,
even when some in your
number and some in mine
prefer to go the other
way and to talk only
about our individual
agendas or the power
of our individual groups.
And I hope and pray
that those of you
who sit here today who
are African-American
or of African ancestry, that
you understand, as we must,
the real need at some point
in time to get beyond blame,
to get beyond excuses,
and to start once
again doing for ourselves.
[APPLAUSE]
If we were to leave here
and to go over to the lab
and sit before any computer
and to request from ourselves
a simple computer print-out of
all the salient issues facing
us as a nation, it is clear
that the list of problems
to be printed out
by that computer
would, in fact, be overwhelming.
Institutionally, government,
military, church, and school
are all under attack for either
real or imagined defects.
Politically, the Joint
Center for Political Studies
in Washington would remind us
that 35 years after passage
of the Voting Rights Act and
30 years after outright efforts
to register and to elect people
that still in this country,
less than 7% of all
the elected officials
are of African or Hispanic
or Asian ancestry.
Socially, that same
print-out would
suggest that the issue
of race and skin color
still dominate too many aspects
of American life, both at home
and abroad.
Economically, it would suggest
to us in the clearest of terms
that after four years
of Congressional
acquiescence to the concept
of Robin Hood in reverse,
the haves now have more, and
the have-nots have none at all.
The gap continues to widen.
[APPLAUSE]
Educationally, it would
point out the obvious--
that too many of
our public schools
are overcrowded
and ill equipped,
and drugs tend to be more
available than textbooks,
and that too many young
people in those schools,
because they are a lot there,
are being promoted because
of their age or because
of their size, only
to be rewarded at
the end of 12 years
with the equivalent
document that would suggest
it was a certificate
of attendance,
but not a meaningful
high school diploma.
And yet we know that the
student in those schools,
not different from
students in other schools,
have one thing
that defines them,
and that is that the
student who makes the grade
is still the one who
comes early and stays
late to learn the
meaning of the lesson,
but never to lessen the
meaning of the assignment,
and that the teacher in those
schools who makes the grade
is still the teacher who
teaches to touch a life
and not just to make a living.
Just a few months
from now, we will
witness what many
in the press will
refer to as a celebration of the
45th anniversary of the Supreme
Court decision--
Brown versus the Board of
Topeka, Kansas, when on May 17,
1954, nine men robed in black
assembled on that historic day
to announce their
unanimous verdict.
There was, in fact,
dancing in the streets.
At black colleges,
classes were suspended
that day and parties
were hastily assembled,
and there was dancing in the
streets of Richmond and Raleigh
and Baltimore and
Washington, and people
began to believe in their hearts
and in the inner-most parts
of their being that our nation
was at long last launched
on an unalterable course
with a firm determination
that in terms of
public education,
we were now prepared to overcome
the legacies of the past.
But in 1969, just a
decade or so later,
a high-ranking official
in the White House
who is now a United
States senator
advised the president
then in what
later became known as the
celebrated "Memorandum
on Public Education"
when he said,
Mr. President, we have made
so much progress moving
black people into the
mainstream of American
economic, educational, and
social life that our nation's
policies from this
point on with respect
to the status of
those people ought
be accorded benign neglect.
That neglect once proposed as
benign in too many respects
today for too many people is
a neglect that is malignant.
And so when we think about
Dr. King and his capacity,
remember also what Randall said.
This was an ordinary
man who was called on
to do extraordinary things.
And I underscore that
because God still
calls on ordinary people--
all of us-- as
Booker T. Washington
once said, to cast our
buckets down where we are,
to pick our own battlefield,
and to make a difference
in a real and meaningful way.
When Dr. Vest talked
about these attacks
on the ability of young
people to matriculate
as a result of efforts
to deny opportunity,
that's all tied into
the exact same thing.
We know that
affirmative action has
met with resistance
from its inception
and that for the last
five years or so,
there has been a
sustained attack
nationwide, a movement
throughout the country
to gut and to destroy
affirmative action as we know
it, and in the process, destroy
diversity programs as well,
programs both in the workplace
and on college campuses.
Prop 209, Initiative 200,
the University of Michigan
case which is now pending,
the Hopwood decision--
in the aggregate, they
chip away at the ability
of people who come behind
you, or at least want
to come behind you, students,
to sit where you sit.
Now, interestingly enough,
the rationale for this attack
has been unsubstantiated reports
of widespread colorblindness.
People just say, well, you
know, things are different
and were a colorblind
society, and so we
don't need to help you
with a Hispanic surname.
We don't need to help
you because you happen
to be of African ancestry.
We don't really need
to help you, either,
because you come
from the Pacific Rim.
We don't have to help you
who grew up in Appalachia.
We don't have to do
anything for anybody
because colorblindness
has broken out
throughout this society.
Oh, if that were the
case, this program
would be more than
a celebration.
It would be a
magnificent celebration.
And so I say to you
and remind myself,
as we think about why
we have come together,
what it means to
remember Dr. King
and what our own personal
challenge is, that it is not
so much the hypocrisy
of the past, the things
that we know about that
we find repulsive--
the institution of slavery, the
attacks on individuals because
of their religious beliefs, the
of their surnames or because
of their sexual preferences.
It is not so much the
hypocrisies of a past
as much as it is for
those people of color
the hypocrisies of the present.
That's what should concern us.
Item number one.
In 1990, the Urban Institute--
bipartisan funding,
bipartisan participation--
conducted a nationwide
study over a number of years
and concluded unequivocally
that there was unequal treatment
of minority job seekers.
Item number two.
In 1991, the Holiday
Health Spa Club chain
was found to have
systematically discriminated
against women of color.
Item number three.
In 1993, Denny's
Restaurant settled
claims of discrimination
because they
refused to serve
black customers who
happened to be six
gentlemen guarding
the president as Secret
Service agents prepared
to take a bullet that day
to preserve democracy.
Item number four, 1994.
The Chevy Chase Bank agrees
to an $11 million settlement
because they red-lined
communities and neighborhoods,
or at least were
accused of doing it,
and refused to go into
court to defend themselves,
as many other institutions
had previously done.
Item 5, 1995.
The Glass Ceiling
Commission concludes
that women, Hispanics, and
African-Americans are still
disproportionately represented
among the nation's working
poor.
Item 6, 1996.
Texaco, the infamous
tape where executives
are caught loosely making
fun of Jewish holidays
and black holidays and
referring to people
as jelly beans of color
and talking very, very
openly about why it's important
not to let those people
have an opportunity.
And lastly, 1998.
Data released under the
Home Mortgage Disclosure Act
showed nationwide that
black and Latino borrowers
were turned down at
increasingly higher rates
when applying for
mortgage loans.
More than 50% of all
those who applied
were denied loans at
banks across this nation.
And so, regrettably,
discrimination
is not an article of the past.
It is instead an
article of the present.
And so what then
really becomes our role
in dealing with what
we are faced with?
We find ourselves
living at a time when
our sense of community can no
longer be taken for granted.
That's for sure.
We find ourselves at a time
where information technology
has made it possible for us
to communicate across oceans,
across continents, across every
conceivable boundary of race
and culture, and to do that
almost instantaneously.
But our technology
has almost also
made it possible for us to
be able to live and work
in complete isolation from our
neighbors and fellow citizens.
Things have changed.
It'd be nice to be
like these birds.
Just fly around all day long.
You know?
[CHUCKLING]
Have a little bite
to eat on that table
and fly up to the balcony.
But things have changed.
[CHUCKLING]
The common experiences that have
made us recognize each other
as members of a
community of Americans
are becoming less
common each year.
Scab labor, unbridled poverty,
second-class citizenship,
and violent crime chip
away at that sense
of community every day.
Hate speech, hate
groups, hate radio,
and hate crimes are
attempting to divide
those same communities
like never before,
and yet we know if we lose
that sense of community,
that same community that
Martin King spoke about
from an old Birmingham
jail, we lose
much of what has made America
distinctive among the nations
of the world.
As foreign visitors
have observed
since the beginning
of this republic,
America's greatest strength
has been her identity
as a group and a collection
of different people
whose common destiny
was more powerful
than their diverse backgrounds
or stations in life.
And that is why people
in this country,
under the umbrella of the NAACP
and hundreds of other groups,
have always made
an attempt to try
to communicate across lines of
race, class, age, and religion.
It's not because they
were foolish or foolhardy.
It's because they understood
the fact that it is harder
to accept that the
road less traveled
is the road less certain, but
it is the proper road for us
to be on anyway.
It is that path that
Randall talked about
that we beat out of
the wilderness that
makes a difference.
The really, really
understanding of what
it means to be on a road less
traveled, where there are not
street lights and
paved sidewalks,
where there is at each turn
some degree of uncertainty,
but certainly at the end of
the road, if we are persistent,
a great deal of satisfaction.
That opposite path, the one
that's paved and well lit,
the one that we
think has no curves--
that's a path of cynicism,
contempt, distrust,
and suspicion.
It is best espoused by the
Timothy McVays of this world.
And that road, to be sure,
leads to separatism, suspicion,
division, and destruction.
And so collectively
and individually,
our charge has been
renewed, regrettably,
by an old plague that
has come back to America,
a plague that has resurfaced
with great abandon,
a national scourge, if
you will, of insensitivity
and intolerance, whether it is
the repugnant act of burning
black churches or
desecrating synagogues,
whether it is increased violence
from militia groups or bombings
of federal buildings or
demonstrations against
immigrants simply because
they cannot speak as we do.
Tolerance, for too many, has
once again become a dirty word.
You look at what happened out
there in Laramie, Wyoming.
The student matriculating--
and because someone thought
they should determine what
his sexual preference ought
to be decided that
they and not God
had the right to take his life.
Look what happened in
June in Jasper, Texas.
300 miles from
nowhere, James Byrd Jr,
on a street corner
trying to get home,
gets grabbed and drug by
a truck for three miles
until his arms
and neck and limbs
are dismembered because he
just happened to be black.
No, if Dr. King were
here, he'd remind us
that Jim Crow Sr. is dead, but
Jim Crow Jr. is alive and well.
[APPLAUSE]
And so the great moral
challenge for all of us
is to separate the
truth from the trick,
and the challenge
rests on our shoulders
because in an era of smaller
vision, rampant apathy,
and celebrated mediocrity,
we so desperately
need those men and women who
will stand up and speak out
for that which is
right and to fight back
against that which is
wrong, to really mean it
when we say that racism, sexism,
and anti-Semitism are wrong,
to know as a matter
of critical fact
that black bigotry is
just as cruel and evil
as white bigotry, to
understand intuitively
that xenophobia and homophobia
and immigrant-bashing and
union-bashing and city-bashing
deplete us as a nation.
They rob us of some
lofty place in history
and relegate us back
to where we have been
and regrettably, in many
respects, are still now.
And so in speaking out as
Dr. King would speak out,
we must be honest and true
to our own sense of fairness,
for the great enemy of the
truth is very often not the lie.
That's deliberate.
It's contrived.
It's dishonest.
The great enemy of
the truth very often
is the myth because that is
persistent and persuasive and
unrealistic.
Too often, we hold fast to the
conclusions of other people.
We subject all facts to a
kind of pre-fabricated set
of interpretations.
As my grandmother said, we
enjoy the comfort of opinion
without the
discomfort of thought.
And yet we have spent 5,000
years as a race of human beings
trying to drag ourselves
out of the primeval slime
by searching for truths
and moral absolutes,
and yet in its purest
form, truth is not
a polite tap on the shoulder.
It is, as Martin Luther
King reminded us,
a howling reproach.
And what Moses brought down
from Mount Sinai 2,000 years ago
was not the 10 suggestions, but
rather a blueprint for life.
[APPLAUSE]
Marabel Gomez said
it earlier, and I
think it bears repeating as we
talk and remember and reflect
on the life of Dr. King, those
words that said that we--
we-- are confronted with
the fierce urgency of now
and that in this unfolding
conundrum of life and history,
there really is such a
thing as being too late,
for procrastination is still
the great thief of time.
And so consequently,
students, the degree
that you will one
day receive from MIT
will, in fact,
represent many things.
It will be a reward for
your academic excellence.
It will be a reminder of
a debt that you can never
repay your parents.
[CHUCKLING]
It will be both a source
of relief and respect
to your professors.
But more than anything, it
will be a license to learn.
And so age has given me the
arrogance and experience
has given me the urgency
to tell you what life looks
like from my side of the river.
My generation was the first
to think that we might not
have any time at all,
and your generation
is the first to be
born knowing it.
And so there will be
those beyond these doors
and beyond this
activity today who
will counsel you to be silent
in this reactionary time.
They will suggest, students,
that you look the other way
and hope for the best.
But I refuse to stand mute
when opportunity is denied
and justice is deferred,
and I challenge you not
to stand mute also.
And so when the timid
come running to you
to say that they fear
even to try anymore,
we must reply as Martin Luther
King did from an old Birmingham
jail that now is the time.
When you are told to wait for
tomorrow or the next tomorrow,
for the next election
or the next generation,
we must reply that
now is the time.
I believe and I humbly
submit to you this morning
that we must use this
occasion, this glittering
reminder of the success
of our experience,
to recommit ourselves to
sharing a basic dream.
It is the dream of Martin Luther
King and Fannie Lou Hamer,
the dream of Dubois
and Washington
and Tubman and Douglass,
the dream of all
those nameless and
faceless people
who made their bodies
bridges over generations
that you might run across and
one day get to the university.
And we must do that not just
through our prose, our poetry,
or our prayers, but also
through our actions--
action which removes a
large part of our distress
by changing the conditions
around us that created it.
And so as I go to my
seat, let me say to you,
and again remind
myself, that I have not
given up on the American idea
or the American possibility.
And I, like Dr. King, would
urge you not to give up also.
I am convinced that
this nation still
stands before the world as
perhaps the last expression
of a possibility of mankind
devising a social order where
justice is the
supreme ruler and law
is but its instrument, where
freedom is the dominant creed
and order but its
principle, where equity
is the common practice
and fraternity
the true human condition,
and to take that belief
and to run with it beyond this
university, beyond your years
of youth, and beyond
all else, and to make
a real difference in this
nation and in your generation.
And I challenge you, as Dr. King
would, to do that right now.
And when they saw him
from afar, even before he
had come near to them,
they conspired against him
to slay him.
And they said one to another,
behold, the dreamer cometh.
Come now, therefore,
and let us slay him.
We will cast him
into some old pit
and say that some evil
beast has devoured him,
and we shall see what
becomes of his dream.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SMITH: Thank you again,
the honorable Kweisi Mfume,
for his inspiring words.
We really appreciate
listening to them,
and I know as a student, I
can take a lot of that back
and use it in my future life.
So thank you again.
Please [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
I now have the honor of
introducing Chancellor Lawrence
S. Bachau, who will present
the 1999 MLK Leadership Awards.
Chancellor Bachau.
[APPLAUSE]
BACHAU: Thank you, Shana.
Thank you very much, Shana.
First, I would like to thank
the committee for the privilege
and honor of being
able to be here
today to present these awards.
This is a day in which we
not only remember Dr. King,
remember his teachings,
remember his legacy,
but we also honor
him by recognizing
those members of
our community who
through their actions
and their deeds
have really embraced and
personified his ideals, who
have, in Randall's words, found
their own way, their path,
who've created their own road.
In doing so, we recognize
a member of our faculty,
we recognize one of our
alumni, and we recognize
one of our students among us.
In many ways, I think
this is a fitting tribute
that we look across MIT to
the various generations that
are represented
within our community.
Before I would like to call up
our honorees today, however,
I have to say something not
as chancellor, but rather
as a member of our faculty.
And I really direct my
comments largely in response
to, I think, the remarkable
words of Randall,
the remarkable words of Maribel.
Those of us who have the
privilege of teaching here
at MIT really bear an
extraordinary responsibility
because we are entrusted
with absolutely extraordinary
students.
And you see today before you not
only in our student speakers,
but also in our students
and our alumni who
we are about to honor the
great privilege that we have,
and indeed, the great burden
and responsibility that we
take among ourselves to try and
lead, to guide, and to inspire.
There are times in which I
think that as faculty at MIT,
we should be required to
take the Hippocratic oath.
First, do no harm.
We really have such
remarkable students,
and they constantly remind
us what a truly remarkable
place this is.
Randall, Mirabel, thank you
again for your inspiring words.
[APPLAUSE]
Our first honoree today is
a member of our faculty--
Alex Slocum.
Alex, would you
please come up here?
[APPLAUSE]
Alex is a remarkable person
in many different dimensions.
He happens to be one of our
most gifted teachers at MIT.
He happens to be
one of our most--
and I mean this warmly, Alex--
unusual personalities and
distinctive personalities
at MIT.
And I think Alex
embraces the very
best of what we hope an MIT
faculty member would be--
a scholar of the first
rank, an inspiring teacher,
and somebody who also pays
extraordinary attention
to his students.
I would like to read to you from
the letter from Dr. Vest that
recognizes Alex for
his accomplishments.
In his letter of nomination,
Professor [INAUDIBLE]----
this is Alex's department
head-- mechanical engineering--
cited your innovative and
intellectually captivating
efforts with MIT
minority students,
and particularly your work
on activities sponsored
by the Urban Design Corps in
the engineering design workshop
of the second summer program.
Creating and developing
products under your supervision
has been an
invaluable experience
for many young people
from diverse backgrounds.
As an enthusiastic
teacher and caring mentor,
you have helped these aspiring
engineers and designers
to acquire the knowledge
and skills that
lead not only to
greater self-confidence,
but also to academic and
professional success.
These generous and
lasting contributions
to the lives of
your students embody
the essence of Dr. King's
philosophy and vision.
Alex, it's my privilege
to recognize you today
as one of the winners of the
Martin Luther King Achievement
Award.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
SLOCUM: Oh, cool.
Thanks, Larry.
I appreciate it.
I wrote a little poem
inspired by Mr. Mfume
because I usually do things
kind of at the moment,
take what I have, and try
to build a road with it.
So let me try this.
To win a battle, the pen
is mightier than the sword.
To build a road, we
will find that the bite
is mightier than the bulldozer.
Two extraordinary students
started me on my road--
Mark Graham, who's
over here somewhere--
Mark, stand up for
a minute, please--
and Marty Culpepper,
who I think Mr. Mfume
met at dinner last night.
I was just your average,
ordinary geek patenting away,
having fun.
And these two young
people made me
realize that there's
a big wilderness,
and if we build this road,
everybody can be a lot happier.
So we have partnered to create
what we call the Urban Design
Corps.
Just like the Peace Corps
strove to provide basic needs
and things for people who
didn't have food or clothing
and shelter, we hope to
build on the internet what
we call the Urban Design Corps,
a place where we will teach
people to create, where they
can take their creations
and post them where businesses
can then take those creations
and employ people
and create jobs.
We're going to harness
the power of creativity,
we believe, throughout
the world to help
all people lift themselves up.
That is our dream, and
that dream is kind of
inspired by Dr. King,
so we have a little poem
that we wrote for him too.
And I'll finish with that
because I'm only allowed
I think 47 more seconds.
[CHUCKLING]
His dream was dedicated
to our parents.
They gave us life.
They shielded us from strife.
They are why we must carry on.
His dream was dedicated
to our everlasting souls.
This is why we will
work into the night.
work for what is right.
This is what bring
us into God's fold.
His dream was dedicated
to our children.
They renew the life within us.
They drive our problems from us.
They are why we must
stay on the right path.
His dream was dedicated to
the Almighty, who gave us
ambition and drive, who gave
us the ability to create,
not stagnate, who we
will not let down.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Can I give this to Mr. Mfume?
BACHAU: Absolutely.
SLOCUM: Should I
do the one picture?
OK.
Mr. Mfume, can you
come back up, please?
Pretty please?
[CHUCKLING]
What I would like
to do is present you
with what we think will be our
kickoff CD for the Urban Design
Corps.
It's called "The Journey
of the Lost Souls,"
and it was written
by Mark Graham.
And we actually
have a tape, too,
so you can listen to
this on the way back.
And the poem for your view.
And then another
fun student I've
had the privilege of knowing--
[INAUDIBLE],, are
you around anywhere?
He here today?
MFUME: There he is.
SLOCUM: He created
this fantastic poster,
and we've inscribed on it "The
Journey of the Lost Souls"
poem.
And I think it
very clearly shows
what path we want to create.
And I think, [INAUDIBLE],,
the big version
of it you have out on
display in lobby 7, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh.
[CHUCKLING]
Well, we'll find it.
Thank you.
MFUME: Thank you.
SLOCUM: For you, sir.
[APPLAUSE]
BACHAU: Thank you,
Alex, for being Alex.
[CHUCKLING]
Our next honoree is
Richard Williamson.
Richard, would you
please come up?
[APPLAUSE]
Richard is an alumnus,
MIT class of 1987.
Richard--
WILLIAMSON: '85.
BACHAU: '85.
My instructions were wrong.
1985.
Richard has chosen a relatively
unusual path for an MIT
alumnus, and that is
that most of the world
tends to think of us--
and I'm an alumnus as
well, so I can say us--
as engineers, as
scientists, as geeks.
Richard, however,
has made his way
in the world in a different way.
He is a teacher in the
Boston public schools,
and not just any
kind of a teacher.
Richard teaches at an
alternative school,
a school of his
choosing, a school which
is for young men and women
who have been expelled
from the Boston public schools.
Richard has chosen a
path where he can really
have an influence on
the lives of people
who are, in many cases,
most in need of inspiration,
of leadership, of
support, and he
has done so in a way that
has touched the lives of many
of Boston's youth.
In addition to his
activities as a teacher
in the Boston public schools--
I have to pull out
Richard's card, which
I think is wonderful--
Richard has also formed
another organization
to help Boston's youth
which has the absolutely
wonderful and inspiring name
of God's Posse Incorporated.
[APPLAUSE]
I read to you from the letter of
award from Dr. Vest to Richard.
In his letter of nomination,
Dr. Ramon E. Samuel of Brigham
and Women's Hospital cited
your unwavering commitment
and selfless service to young
people in the neighborhoods
of Roxbury and Dorchester.
Your efforts as a teacher,
mentor, and community leader
have brought hope
and inspiration
to the lives of promising
young people who
otherwise may have been lost,
neglected, or forgotten.
Your outstanding work
and strong contributions
are a fitting tribute to
the legacy of Dr. King
and to all who passionately
believe in the great tradition
of education and service.
Richard, in giving
you this award today,
I want you to know
that through your work,
you honor all of MIT, its
alumni, and all the people that
serve our great community.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAMSON: I'm reminded
of the preacher that
said when Jesus was coming
into the town of Jerusalem
and the crowds were
cheering and worshipping him
that the donkey realized that
the praise was for the Lord
and not for him, and I
feel like that donkey.
Scriptures teach to whom much
is given, much is required.
And I felt that I'd been one
who's been blessed and given
much, and so I felt
it my obligation
to seek a way to give
back, not knowing how, not
knowing that path to take.
But I had the opportunity
to come to MIT
and to be taught by
this illustrious faculty
and to learn some things that
challenge me and taught me
that anything is possible
if you work hard at it.
And God opened up
doors for me to be
able to leave here and go
into the Roxbury community
and work with young men,
particularly young men who
are considered the
throwaways, the castaways,
the super-predators, those whom
the prisons are being built
for, those who institutions
are not looking forward to them
coming, and to see in them
the potential for our country,
to see in them a
leadership, to see
in them gifts and
talents and abilities,
to see in them the gift of God.
And God has privileged
me with the ability
to be able to reach them,
teach them, and to lead them,
and I thank God for that
opportunity and that privilege.
I'd like to acknowledge this
morning also my co-founder, Mr.
Chris Womack, who I work
with in God's Posse.
Can you stand up, please?
[APPLAUSE]
And two young men
that I work with,
Mr. Steven Maguire,
who's a member of God's
Posse, and Mr.
Daniel Davis, who is
a senior at Community Academy
in Roxbury where I work.
Finally, I'd just like to say
Dr. King said a man is not
worthy to live until he's found
something worth dying for,
and I found in these
young men, young men
in the streets of Boston,
something worth dying for.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BACHAU: Thank you, Richard.
Our third honoree, Adriana Ogi.
Adriana, would you
please come up?
[APPLAUSE]
Now, I have to tell something
which most people in this room
just know from having
been around this place.
But for our visitors, I
have to share with you
the fact that MIT students
probably work harder and longer
than any other people
in any other job
on the face of the planet.
In fact, we have an
expression at MIT
that if you can't get your
work done in 24 hours in a day,
start working nights.
So it's all the
more remarkable when
one encounters a
student like Adriana,
who, in spite of bearing the
burden of an extraordinarily
challenging curriculum, in
spite of having accomplished
academically at an
extraordinarily high level,
still manages to
find time amidst all
of her other activities
to serve her community
and to do so with grace and
with honor and with dignity,
and to find time for others
who are less fortunate
and to find time to
pass on the tradition
and inspired others so that
they may accomplish someday
as she has done as well.
I read to you from
Adriana's letter of award.
In her letter of nomination,
Dean Anne Davis Shaw,
advisor to the National Society
of Hispanic Professional
Engineers, cited the
depth of your commitment
to helping fellow students
in the MIT community.
Your outstanding
work as a leader
has motivated many
peers, and you
have contributed
effectively to a range
of student organizations.
As a calculus
teacher's assistant
with the Minority Introduction
to Engineering and Science
program--
MITES-- you inspired 30 talented
secondary school students
to strive for higher
academic goals.
Equally admirable
is your ability
to be fully engaged in
your own scholarship
while never losing sight
of the needs of others.
The Martin Luther
King Jr. Committee
believes that you represent
much of what Dr. King wanted
for all youth in this society.
Your dedication to his
vision is a fitting tribute
to that legacy.
Adriana, you represent
a community of scholars,
a community of students who
themselves, each and every one,
are extraordinary, and even
among this extraordinary group,
you stand out.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
OGI: Thank you.
I am very honored to
receive this award,
and I would like to thank
the MLK Committee and the OME
staff for all of their
hard work and efforts
in making this event a success.
I never thought
that my name would
be associated with such an
excellent individual as Dr.
Martin Luther King,
Jr. When I think
of Dr. King and the
motivation he possessed,
it makes me ask
myself, what else can I
do to become a better leader?
Whether I become a
professor in the future
or whether I decide
to work in industry,
I always want to keep
Dr. Martin Luther King,
Jr's characteristics in mind.
During the years
when Dr. King was
at the top of the
civil rights movement
leading hundreds of people,
he never became power hungry.
I deeply admire
him for that, and I
pray that in times of
success and achievement,
humility will not be forgotten.
What I admire the
most about Dr. King
is that God always
came first in his life.
When there were struggles,
he would pray to God
to give him strength
and patience.
And I'm sure that when
things were going well,
his first instinct was to
thank God for his blessings.
These are things that I always
want to keep close to my heart.
I accept this award
with gratitude.
I also accept it as a challenge
to continue in my path
to educate myself as well as
others, and at the same time,
never forget the
important things in life--
humility and faith in God.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BACHAU: Before I turn
things back to Shana,
I just wanted to add one
more comment and observation.
I, too, would like to thank Mr.
Mfume for his truly inspiring
remarks, which were
delivered with passion,
with grace in a way that I
think everybody in this room
was moved.
We have a problem at MIT,
and that is getting students
to come to classes at 9
o'clock in the morning,
and I think we've
discovered a solution.
And so I would like to
extend an invitation
to Mfume that if he can hold a
crowd like this at this hour,
we'd love to have
you teach physics.
[CHUCKLING]
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SMITH: Thank you very
much, and congratulations
to all the recipients.
Now it's my pleasure to
introduce Provost Robert A.
Brown, who will recognize the
1998-1999 Martin Luther King
Jr. Visiting Professors.
Provost Brown.
[APPLAUSE]
BROWN: Thank you, Shana.
This morning has reminded me
of an extraordinary number
of things, but I
think it's reminded us
all of the commitment we
have to have of building
an academic community
that exemplifies
the path that Martin
Luther King, Jr. challenged
us to follow.
The Martin Luther King, Jr.
Visiting Professor Program
began in 1994 to bring to
MIT outstanding scholars
to participate in teaching
and research at the Institute
and to enrich our community.
Appointments to this
program are made
upon recommendations from the
departments and to the provost.
This year, there have
been five Martin Luther
King, Jr. visiting professors.
I'd like to take
this opportunity
to recognize the four
individuals who are here
this morning and to introduce
you, at least through my words,
to the fifth.
I'll ask each one to stand at
the table where I was seated
and give you a brief
description of them.
Dr. Lloyd Dimitrius.
[APPLAUSE]
Dr. Dimitrius is visiting
in the Department
of Brain and Cognitive Science.
He is with the Department of
Biology at Harvard University
and is an expert in
mathematics and biophysics
and in the wonderful world of
nonlinear dynamical systems.
His research at MIT has spanned
across biology, chemistry,
in brain and cognitive
science, and is now
taking him into bioengineering
and chemical engineering
this spring.
His teaching has been in the
course evolutionary psychology
in BSC, co-taught with
Professor Stephen Pinker,
truly integrated
in the community.
Let me introduce
Mr. Sterling Hunter.
Sterling?
[APPLAUSE]
Mr. Hunter is a visiting
professor of management
in the Sloan School, where
his research is focusing
on organizational design and
organizational consequences
of information theory.
At MIT, Mr. Hunter
is also interested
in the virtual organization.
His teaching has been
in the graduate subject
in strategic management.
Let me introduce
Dr. Linda Jordan.
Linda.
[APPLAUSE]
Dr. Jordan is visiting the
Department of Chemistry.
She's currently an
associate professor
in the Department of Chemistry
at North Carolina Agricultural
and Technical State University.
Her research is in the
area of human biochemistry
and expertise is in enzymes,
especially in the enzyme that
affects diseases in man,
including arthritis, asthma,
pulmonary disorders, and cancer.
At MIT, she's
focused on research,
along with
undergraduate students,
on cloning a specific
enzyme and examining
its structural properties.
Dr. [INAUDIBLE]
Let me introduce Dr.
Pamela McCarley Bell.
Pamela.
[APPLAUSE]
Pamela is visiting in the
Department of Aeronautics
and Astronautics.
She's currently an
associate professor
in industrial engineering
and management
systems in the University
of Central Florida.
Her research focuses
on the development
of intelligent software
and predictive models
to address information
warfare, information security,
and human factors problems.
She's worked here in the field
of human impact of information
security, where she's
brought her expertise
to a range of groups in
the aero-astro department,
including the human factors
groups and the group focused
on intelligence systems.
She's been teaching a seminar
on information security,
and she's served as the advisor
to seven freshmen and two
graduate students while here.
Not with us today is
Dr. Arnold Stancel,
who visited this fall in
the Department of Chemical
Engineering.
He's a professor
currently at the Georgia
Institute of Technology and
has returned this spring
to teach there.
While at MIT, he brought to
bear his enormous experience.
Arnie spent 31 years at
Mobil before coming back
into the academic profession.
While here, he consulted on
energy issues in the Energy
Lab, helped supervise
graduate students,
and taught in a core
thermodynamics course
in chemical engineering.
Each of these individuals
has enriched the environment
in MIT enormously
over their time here,
and we look forward
to, in many cases,
the time they have left with us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SMITH: Thank you, Provost Brown,
for recognizing our faculty.
We will now continue
with some announcements
that are relevant to this
morning's celebration.
First, there will
be an installation
of the Martin Luther King,
Jr. Design Project in Lobby 7
at 11:00 AM.
[INAUDIBLE] will be performing
at noon in Lobby 7 also.
There will be a
conference called
"Sisters in Cyberspace
Youth Conference"
held here at the
Institute on February 6.
Finally, they will--
oh, excuse me there.
Fourthly, there will
be a presentation
in the Black
Student Union, which
is right through those doors,
hosted by the Installation
Committee from 4 to 5 PM today.
Finally, the South Mass Choir
will be performing in Lobby 7
also at 5 PM.
So I hope you all can
attend those events.
Now I'd like to introduce
Champlain Betsy Draper, who
will offer the benediction for
the close of this morning's
program.
Champlain Draper?
DRAPER: May everyone
stand together, please?
May we pray.
Oh, God and father of humankind,
forgive our foolish ways.
May our renewal today starve the
beast of racism and favoritism,
never to devour the
dream of justice for all.
May our actions, our
conduct, our words, our deeds
nourish the dream and to
the reality of harmony.
Today, we ask for courage to
serve and to continue to serve,
to never give up as
components of change
for good in an
ever-changing world.
We ask for direction.
We ask for your
sustaining presence
as we rally round the
standard of blind equality,
leaving behind in the pit
our desires for blind power
and pride.
Oh, God and father
of humankind, we
look forward to a better day.
We ask these things.
Amen.
SMITH: Well, originally we had
scheduled for the MIT Gospel
Choir to sing, but
now we are going
to move on to just a closing.
I hope-- you may all be seated.
You may all be
Seated.
I hope you all have enjoyed
this morning's program as much
as I have and have taken a
moment to reflect and remember
Dr. King and the life and the
legacy that he has left behind.
Thank you all for
coming, and of course, we
hope to see you next year.
And this concludes the 25th
Annual Martin Luther King Jr.
Celebration.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]